welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and marvel's what if
we'll open our minds to multiversal
possibilities that honestly look
less and less hypothetical in the
live-action future of mcu but i think
this is going to be the perfect road map
for how we
understand the more rule-bending marvel
titles like loki or wandavision while
giving us some awesome looking alternate
reality stories different
genres the final mcu performance of
chadwick boseman
we're really gonna love this series when
it comes to disney plus most likely
summer 2021
i am gonna break down this new trailer
frame by frame
for all the visual clues and easter eggs
to help us decipher what each of these
what-if scenarios will be
let's get started
space time
time time reality
it's more than a linear path it's a
prism
of endless possibility right we hear the
voice of jeffrey wright as uwatu the
watcher our host and guide throughout
this anthology series kind of like ron
sterling of the twilight zone
or the crypt keeper tales from the crypt
watchers are marvel cosmic beings who
oversee and observe the multiverse uatu
being the watcher assigned to our
universe we first met watchers in the
mcu back in guardians of the galaxy vol
2 the tall bald dudes at stan lee bored
with his stories
anyway before i was so rudely
interrupted at that time
i was a federal express man now what if
was a series of hypothetical scenario
marvel comics with titles like what if
uncle ben hadn't died or what if the
hulk had the brain of bruce banner which
of course the in-game filmmaker said
inspired banner in that movie while
these one-off episodes might not
be official mcu cannon uatu himself
totally is
and absolutely could pop up in a
live-action mcu title like thor love and
thunder doctor strange to the multiverse
madness for guardians vol 3. here he
says the word
space time reality interestingly the
names of three out of six
infinity stones those stones being
condensed versions of the six core
abstract elements behind the universe's
creation during the big bang
so he leaves out mind power and soul
making me wonder if each of these
what-if episodes will flip on the axes
of one of those first three constants
characters in different spaces in
different chronological times
in different realities meanwhile maybe
the upcoming marvel disney plus
series will center around the other
three themes falcon winner soldier about
power
wand division about the mind stone loki
about his
soul but then again loki is definitely
more of a time-centric series
we'll see here nick fury wipes frost off
of cap's shield but remember in the mcu
fury himself didn't discover cat frozen
in that ice
and we know that the cap episode of this
series is the captain
britain peggy carter with a different
shield with the union jack so i suspect
this
is just from a different episode more on
that later star-lord opens the doors of
the morag temple but we know from later
shots
this is not peter quill this is t'challa
and then a close-up of the time stone in
the eye of agamotto but again this might
not be around the neck of steven strange
we'll see more of that as we move on
well that doesn't sound ominous at all
now fury speaks in a different setting
that should look familiar not unlike the
shield
grid setup around the mjolnir crater in
thor a site that i pointed out in that
overhead shot contained the hidden
letters of
shield s-h-i-e-l-t we also see
thor himself from that moment in the
thunderstorm as he went to go try to
lift mule near but he failed
we also get that quick shot of iron man
eating donuts when he was hungover in
iron man 2
one of these stories must feature fury's
big week remember when thor
and iron man 2 and the incredible hulk
and cat and the epilogue of cap
all kind of took place in that same week
leading up to loki's attack and avengers
and yes star-lord t'challa in nimorak
temple behind him you can see that
column with the magnetic field
that contained the orb now the orb is no
longer there so t'challa's got it the
marvel studios title card shows us
uwatu the watcher peering out from
behind it and his perceptive eyes linger
as we fade to black now later on we see
how the animation onuwatu appears to
cast him as a silhouette in space like
his form
containing stars and planets folks this
is pretty much the way marvel comics
depicted the cosmic entity eternity
i'm not sure if the show is going to
draw a connection between the two things
but i am just saying this abstract
depiction
leaves marvel room to re-visualize
jeffrey wright in a different form if
they ever want to bring him into live
action
next clip
i was promised an army
you have a super soldier
okay here we see the shots of what is
confirmed to be the first episode of the
series
what if peggy carter became cap the
super soldier serum flows into her
howard stark moves the shades actually i
love how both father and son in this
trailer are both
in shades and a thick peggy comes out of
that chamber
and then in full captain britain gear
she flips a truck looks awesome and it
looks like we're gonna see different
world war two missions in europe
more tied to the british campaign than
the american invasion
like maybe she'll help liberate france
maybe we'll see dunkirk
originally captain britain in the marvel
comics is brian braddock a multiversal
version of captain america where he's
just like from the uk
that actually might be brought into
live-action canon this just looks like a
hypothetical scenario of peggy got the
serum
next clip
oh you sure don't seem too freaked out
about all this kid
what you doing out there all by yourself
anyway exploring
the world sounds fun right in this
section we
see the next episode we know about what
if t'challa became star-lord
the ravager's ship floats down just as
it did in the guardians of the galaxy
prologue except now instead of missouri
it's
wakanda over a young t'challa with his
techy vibranium spear
remember peter quill screamed but
because t'challa has plenty of
familiarity with advanced tech he says
and because t'challa is totally on board
with this he and yondu seem to get along
great
there's also this shot of steven strange
and the episode i'm most
curious about because notice his clothes
here he is wearing the tux that he wore
during this car accident his bow tie is
there but it is loosened there are
bruises on his face presumably from that
car accident though his hands are not
shattered
he looks worried here as these symbols
float around him and later we see a form
of doctor strange with a female
character at his feet i'm thinking this
episode is gonna be
what if christine palmer died in doctor
strange's crash
and now doctor strange's reasons for
seeking out magic are not to selfishly
heal his own hands but out of guilt for
his distracted driving and ego getting
christine killed he must now embrace
sorcery to try to bring his love back
from the dead and obviously
it's not gonna go too well next clip but
why stop at one world
when we can show you all of them
[Music]
i am the watcher
okay here a very cool looking shot of
peggy hitching a ride on an
early ironman prototype suit designed
presumably by howard stark fittingly it
looks very mark one
iron mongerie which an old school
industrious like howard stark
and like obadiah stain would have
conceived the iron man suit to be we
also know from earlier footage that
skinny steve will ride in this thing
kind of like bruce banner in the
hulkbuster suit infinity war another
shot shows bucky on this subway train
now we know from the other shots that he
is turning to look at
a zombie captain america giving us
another confirmed episode
what if the avengers were zombies based
on the marvel zombies comics now i say
avengers here though it could just be
zombie cap in fact that
could be what's going on when fury wipes
the frost off cap's shield maybe he
finds his body but when he unearths that
thing he finds that it has turned into a
zombie during this period maybe left
with some kind of hydra infection
though i will say it is interesting that
bucky appears to have the black
vibranium
arm that he got in infinity war after
his time with cap in civil war after his
time in wakanda so i'm not really sure
what the timeline of this hypothetical
reality
is and if you are into streaming horror
content
i want to thank our friends at shutter
for sponsoring this video as the world's
premiere streaming service for horror
thriller and supernatural content
shudder is spooky 24 7 365. just because
halloween has come and gone doesn't mean
the scares don't continue
sign up for shutter and get access to
the largest collection of acclaimed
horror movies
in series streamed right to your
favorite devices unlimited access to the
largest
fastest growing human curated selection
of thrilling and dangerous entertainment
with no ads for just
5.99 a month new shockers and thrillers
get added every week
and shutter works on your smart tv your
xbox one apple tv any other device
they've got exclusive titles that you
won't find anywhere else like scare me
starring the boys aya cash and snl's
chris redd i really like their
documentary films and tv series we used
their great series
cursed films for background research
when we were doing horror content this
halloween
i'm really excited to watch the doc leap
of faith william friedkin on the
exorcist the exorcist is a movie where
the story behind the story is really
just as scary as the story itself so get
started streaming the best horror
thriller in supernatural content
shutter's expertly curated selection
includes titles like the acclaimed
tigers are not afraid
one cut of the dead revenge and the
creep show tv series
produced by greg nicotero and based on
the famous films of george romero
to try shutter free for 30 days go to
shutter.com and use the promo code
rockstars that's shudder.com and use the
promo code rockstars for a free 30-day
trial
oh and another interesting horror shot
there is this look of steven strange
with his shadow
taking a menacing form behind him this
could be how his shadow bizarro self
splits away from him
and how they end up in a fight i
shouldn't have referenced preserved
that's a dc thing i'm sorry but next
another intriguing shot
loki arriving at the u.n actually that
might be t'challa into chaka in the
front row there
loki notice is flanked by the asgardian
royal guard
whoa so are we looking at a what if loki
won
in avengers or what if loki became
worthy of mjolnir
maybe kinda i actually think we're gonna
see a bit of what if loki won in the
loki series but i actually think this is
a fifth episode
what if thor failed making loki king of
asgard
so notice how along with the thor shots
we get this close-up of hawkeye when he
aims the arrow down at thor
in that moment remember in the movie
hawkeye decided last second to refuse to
take the shot guess he just decided he
liked thor
but what if haki let that arrow fly and
it struck thor because notice in this
shot of nick fury with the guns pointed
upward at something else shows hawkeye's
arrow stuck
in something suggesting that hawkeye
definitely released that arrow
and think about it he never misses so
that could lead to fury now looking up
and saying
that's ominous and that ominous thing
could be loki and his forces
successful arriving to midgard to carry
out his plan because think about it now
thor never would have gotten to prove
himself worthy loki would be
unopposed in his assent to the throne of
asgard and now he would carry out his
plans to invade midgard and
extend his rule over the earth's
governing body in this case the u.n
though presumably loki would then be
opposed by wakanda and the black panther
which would be a dope battle but then a
shot of this
heavenly looking library there's a pink
blossom tree
kind of reminds me of the tree in the
camartage courtyard maybe these books
are part of a vast sorcerer library
though
it could also be the yidracil world's
tree of asgard which was also in the
center of an asgardian vault of
knowledge
the orbital spiral pattern on the floor
in front of it does remind me of the
various depictions the way idris still
connects to the nine realms now it is a
bit hard to make out who isn't during
the space they got a scepter bandage on
the middle finger
big shield on the back either bald or
has a cap-like helmet but still i am
assuming this is connected to the doctor
strange episode because we later see
who i assumed to be doctor strange in
this setting floating all the library
books around himself and then with a
very eternity looking uatu we move on
i am your guide through these vast new
realities
follow me and dare to face the unknown
all right peggy mounts the iron man mark
one armor as they take off and sparks
also fly between peggy and skinny steve
and then a shot of the milano soaring
into nowhere you can see that purple
roofed building that is the collector's
vault
we also see the collector himself in
earlier tivon but yeah now leading this
will be t'challa which does make me
wonder if they are gonna keep that ego
lineage or if t'challa was just
abducted randomly and if t'challa was
not in wakanda for the events of black
panther does that set the stage for
killmonger to return to wakanda
unopposed and take over wakanda
and then back to this shot of iron man
with the donuts since this would have
been set during fury's big week
this could be shortly after thor's
presumed failure and loki's presumed a
rival in victory which would also place
fury's defrosting of cap
part of that loki episode as well then
we get a shot at captain marvel which
could be from just a sixth episode
premise that i'm less sure about or i'm
thinking it could be the zombies episode
maybe carol danvers is another avenger
who might have to join bucky in clearing
out all these super zombies
then captain peggy leads the howling
commandos she replaces cap in that
iconic shot from the first avenger and
then this epic shot of strange
looks like the darker version of strange
there are these gray bags around his
eyes
right before he releases the dark energy
perhaps in order to save his love from
the afterlife strange must battle a dark
doppelganger of himself
and then after the what if title we move
on to the final clip
give me the tour
so star-lord t'challa talks too that is
howard the duck there so that places him
in the collector's vault where we know
how the duck was you can also see all
the other tanks behind him now t'challa
is wearing the black panther vibranium
necklace confirming that he either had
it with him when he was abducted as a
kid
or he might have fashioned his own just
using similar tech
i do love the way he says give me the
toy in the same cadence that chadwick
boseman said
get this man [ __ ] and then we end in
this crazy fight between strange and his
darker doppelganger there is a lot going
on here there is a bridge behind
him that looks like one of the manhattan
bridges this could be set in a version
of manhattan or maybe an underworld
reflection of manhattan and then when
that doppelganger grabs strange breaking
through his spell
his hand is a monstrous green claw that
it was not before
so are we looking at a scroll are we
looking at a shape-shifting demon are we
looking at the entity nightmare
let me know which of these what-if
scenarios you are most excited to see
again we are only seeing footage from
what looks like five to six
episodes here it is expected to be a 10
episode season
based on the cast we're also likely to
get an ant-man episode maybe another
that follows the ragnarok characters
and the what-if comics there's also a
thanos joining the avengers what if
story that i would love to see it did a
video about that last year now if you
have not already be sure to check out
all my other in-depth breakdowns and
reactions to the other big trailers that
came out of disney's investor day
it's like we have stuff to talk about
again isn't that nice 2020 has been a
difficult year of theory spinning
thanks for your patience i've really
just been trying to keep you entertained
day to day
it really has not been easy but one way
you can help support this channel is by
checking out all of our great merch
options that we've been releasing
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at eavos follow new rockstars
and socials thank you for watching
boom boom you looking for this
[Music]
you